someone okay so cloud in seattle wants
to know has travis ever tried ce5 since
the incident and if so what were his
takeaways
what is
what's that i don't know because people
keep mentioning ce5 so if those in the
comments can let me know what ce5 is
then i can i don't know what's that
travis now okay so i probably didn't try
it
is that a type of hypnosis is that uh is
he the reason why it's taken me a while
to come up with questions is because
not only am i reading some of the
audience questions but i'm
i want to ask you
i want to ask you more details about
these
beings but i don't want you to
be on the defensive because i'm not a
i'm not a debunker i'm not a skeptic
i'm on your side or at least
i'm not against you i appreciate that
but you know the audience is huge and
anybody that wants to take something and
turn it into something that's not uh
there's are actually few and far between
but there's
people like that
do you think that these
that these people the ones with helmets
that calmed you
that were there or at least you think
were there to calm you do you think that
they walk among us
have you seen any strange people
yeah i actually said that that they
would pass in a crowd you wouldn't go
whoa there's that kind of odd looking
robotic human or something like that
no i think that they would pass in a
crowd have you seen any people but you
said that they gave you a strange
feeling at least with their eyes it
wasn't
there's something not right about their
eyes
have you encountered any people like
that i never could put my finger on
exactly what it was what color the way
they the pupil constricts or whatever i
i don't know there's just something
a little unusual about that so ce5 is a
term describing the fifth category of
close encounters with extraterrestrial
intelligence characterized by mutual
bilateral communication rather than
unilateral contact
so did you communicate with them
well i stick to the stuff i can document
so
nothing to report there
that's i know that's disappointing
people love
there's so many people that have had an
experience and they'll
expound on whatever
but